it was great to meet Dylan because he is
a stand-up comedian so he had us all
rolling and laughter from the minute he
walked in the office into the GQ fashion
department but what we noticed first off
is the fact that underneath his kind of
baggy ish clothes was of someone who had
a very athletic kind of swimmer build so
this is a guy who is six foot six but
he's in proportion so what we wanted to
do is not only help him kind of come a
little bit down to the ground but also
celebrate the fact that he has this very
athletic physique he's got narrow hips
he's got wide shoulders and he's got
nice slim legs this is the perfect
person for a suit he just have never
found a suit that fit him this is a case
where you know Dylan said to me okay I'm
six six aren't I a custom suit guys
don't I have to have my suits made like
well no you don't it's like there's a
lot of companies that make Long's and
again if you're six six if you're 6 7
you've got to be wearing a long so what
we did is we put him in a dolce gabbana
pale grey suit and he is in the shoulder
because the suit always has to fit you
in the shoulder a lot of people think
it's the length a lot of people which is
important but a lot of people think the
minute they put the jacket on it's got
to be comfortable or the sleeves has to
be the right length
those are all those are all myths first
of all the sleeves can always be
shortened or lengthened and a suit being
comfortable the suit can be comfortable
but you're not going to be really
playing touch football in it so it
doesn't be that comfortable you want it
to have structure to it so if it fits in
the shoulder and the length is right
pretty much you've got a homerun so when
you're this tall you want to think about
a few things you want to think about
always bowling along you want to think
about light colors like this pale gray
and you want to think of wearing your
trousers with cuffs and you want to
think about getting all the proportions
right and keeping it very simple this is
not the time to be wearing pinstripes
this is not the time to be wearing a
plaid and this is not the time to be
shrinking behind that dark suit another
thing that we did for Dylan is we gave
him a really cool haircut I don't
he's had his hair cut this well in years
and actually upgraded his glasses to
something that was a little bit more
contemporary and definitely a softer
color more of a tortoise Brown rather
than the black pair that he was wearing
which went a lot better with his skin
tone so all in all I think Dylan is
ready for the stage